is here with us doubling his score
peter i
obviously couldn't avoid making mention
of the fact that you've had a difficult
tournament so far
to this point
draw today kind of stabilizes things a
little bit
tell us your thinking process coming
into today well i just wanted to play a
game of chess and like bishop d3 uh pe
is is not much but uh you know nobody
really has a clear idea what to do
against the neither of these days and uh
sem did not have any particular prior
experience against bishop d3 but he
played what i thought well like i didn't
prepare much but i took a look at the
file and it seemed to me that exactly
what he played is probably the sort of
the sanest and the the
uh
the best way of replying and uh
true to form sam samuel is generally
well prepared everywhere including lines
which
he you know by right shouldn't be
expecting on the day uh and yeah we got
this really strange position in which
not very much i think was happening at
any point but you know the one
interesting position we had is the one
in which he repeated moves i think
which is which is kind of curious and i
can see on your screen it says zeros
everywhere but it's it's very it's very
strange it's like starting from here
i don't really know what either of us
wants which is a very like it's a very
confusing position to play because it
seems like nothing much is happening but
i think it's slightly easier to play
with black because for instance like
rook c6 rookie qc8 is a way
not to create threads but maybe to
improve because not not much is going on
in the e file but maybe if you if you
double on the c file at some point
something will go to c4
and it's i think it's harder for me to
imagine where my pieces are going
uh and i was you know considering my my
track record in this tournament in in
situations where there's a complicated
position with not a lot of time on the
on the clock i was kind of worried and
honestly i missed something when i i saw
bishop d7 and i thought
there is this repetition which honestly
i don't think i'm better i don't think i
should be avoiding repetitions
and there's also the move queen of f8
which is what i was
going to discuss before guys before you
get to that
our panel was surprised by the move h5
were you i thought i thought it's fine i
thought it's a very logical way to
continue here
you don't really threaten h4 but you
know there's definitely some structures
in which uh the the idea of landing the
poland h4 much later on uh could be
could be an issue and in fact i wasn't
very happy about having to play h3 i was
i was choosing between h3 and king h1 in
that position when i when i played h3
because you kind of have to have
something as a reply to knight g4
eventually and it's either stopping it
all together with h3 or you prepare
bishop g1 as a reply it's one of one of
the two ways and
h3 was better in some tactical positions
but it also creates some potential dark
dark square issues and king ishwan had
had other problems
yeah you had to calculate some things um
but yeah
going to going into the final position
we actually kind of had a slight
disagreement with with sam about that
because we spoke very briefly and he
said he i don't think i can continue but
after 95 instead of after takes takes
where he played queen of 627 seemingly
without
uh you know too much too much doubt i
think queen of fate is a very
interesting option
uh and what i blundered well blunder is
maybe a strong word compared to some
other blunders i've made in this
tournament i i wanted to go rook before
here and if rook takes c2 i think i have
a very strong q in d1 move here because
rugby seven knight of three check is
very unclear
uh
i really don't want to give up that dark
square bishop i think it's incredibly
important for me to preserve the dark
square bishop here but i do have an
intermediary move queen d1 here
attacking the rook keeping my attack on
the b7
pawn and also preserving exactly
protecting the default bishop for you
know eventual knight of three check
tactics
and
this position i calculated and i thought
i'm you know not worse here at least and
then i realized that after look before
there is a very sane kind of non
non-forcing move instead of rook takes
c2 you can play with c6 here
and in my mind i thought okay this
allows knight f6 check so it cannot be
good but i lose the e4 pawn if i do that
and i don't think i have enough
compensation
uh despite winning the dark square
bishop the knight on e5 just does such a
good job of blocking all of my you know
quote unquote dark star the dark square
initiative here that i don't think i can
do this at all
and i think of the bishop c6 sam said he
didn't think he could be better after
something like c3 but this is exactly
the structure i was going to to mention
like bishop d5 vg5 queen e7 or rook c7
rook c7 i don't know which one is
stronger
oh there's also 93 here which i did not
see but even if we talk about you know
the structural
assessment of this position uh you go a
five you double on the e file and you
start making progress on the king side
and this is like a very classical you
know happening in
heaven and i can't yeah i'm not in the
right mood for this it's a it's a kind
of a running gag me trying to pronounce
heaven england correctly but i
i can't do it right now i gotta gargle
first
but yeah like i i feel like i'm obliged
to do it every time you know it comes up
but i'm just not in the right frame of
mind
so like i think bishop takes d5 is a
huge big threat there and
in view of that after bishop c6 i was
choosing between two positions i can
take on e5 and play bishop c4
or i can play actually i think i can
play bishop c4 straight away
so there's there's this position which i
couldn't really assess
or somewhat shockingly i think i can go
bishop c4 because after knight c4 bishop
g7
once again unless i've blundered
something spectacular which i've done
many a time in this event uh qg796 is
strong so you have to take with the king
and i go rooksy for bishop d5 quincy
three check and i'm i think just in time
to recapture on d5 and i suspect i don't
lose this queen and rook
uh my king is definitely
the the unsafer one of the two but i
think there is little enough on the
board for me to
you know to be able to start threatening
some kind of c4 before c5 counterplay so
that some sort of simplification and
draw probably results here
so that's one choice and the other one
as i said is to take on is to take on e5
and go bishop c4 which is quote unquote
more ambitious but could also be
incredibly bad if black manages to
stabilize because like currently i
appear to be exerting some pressure on
the f7 pawn but like what happens after
queen e8 let's say i don't know queen e8
queen queen g3 king h7 or something like
this yeah not blundering any tactics and
you know my center could very easily
just collapse here and i could be in
tremendous amounts of trouble
so
my issue was i kind of blundered that
going in but after queen e1 bishop d7 i
don't think i have a particularly good
choice
so i tried making the move knight fd5
you know with that as confidence as
confident of a mug as possible
and kind of you know
invite sam to play queen e6 which he did
i once again i i can see i can see on
your screen that machine is not
particularly impressed about queen of
fate for whatever reason uh but yeah for
me
in particular the way the way this has
been going
uh yeah i i kind of
liked seeing queen six there you were a
last-minute replacement for alexander
grishok as dariush was also a last
minute replacement in this tournament do
you feel like both of you have been
affected by that for
the same reasons you didn't know you
were going to play you had to jump in at
the last second you couldn't prepare for
the players it's not it's not really
that i i can't speak for darish but i
you know with me i think um
uh i i do like playing in like when i
when i told you before the tournament
that i like playing these fields i i'm
not lying but
uh it's incredibly important for me in
particular these days to start well
and uh
you know the combinations of it's kind
of weird in this tournament to complain
about pairings but starting with three
blacks out of the first four against
you know the the top the top
uh
three like the i'm playing the tour
participants so far you know
uh
not really playing i mean today was i
think my first game against the wild the
fellow wild card uh so a slightly a
slightly softer start oh
specifically i think if i don't lose to
mvl like
my sort of general
state of mind is just so so much better
uh compared that
possibly that would have made that would
have made some difference because uh
i don't think it's even lack of
preparation i'm just
you know nowhere near playing uh
you know anyway you know my my best game
is not this hopefully you know i would i
would like to think that this is yeah i
would like to think this is not my a
game and uh
yeah
the you know
the importance of a good start in a
tournament like this really for me from
i think for everybody but for me in
particular just cannot be overstated
it's just
it makes such a huge difference
you answer any questions no other than
uh peter enjoy your rest day recharge
the batteries and uh give him hell in
the second half
what are you trying to do for the rest
for a given definition of hell yeah
no no plans so far i don't know whatever
presents itself really you know
laundry is probably
very important but also you you did go
elk watching yeah but i don't think i
don't think we're doing that again i
can't really force force alejandro to
although like forces may be a strong
work because it was enjoyable but you
know i like the else we had a good time
over there we did have a good time but
like we've we've done that the czech
there's there's already a checklist yeah
there's a few more things around st
louis i'll have to show you around yeah
there's the we'll we'll see we'll see
what can be done yeah all right well
begin your rest now and then take
entirety of tomorrow to get ready for
the next day thank you